que tiene putin en mente que piensa los
ucranianos pero también su propio pueblo
y el resto del mundo se hacen estas
preguntas tiene el presidente ruso la
intención de invadir a ucrania como la
urss invadió afganistán hace 40 años
quiere putin sacar al presidente
excelencia del poder por la fuerza y
reemplazarlo por un gobierno a su gusto
antes de irse quiere ir aún más lejos y
atacar a otros países el misterio de
putin sigue sin resolverse y los que le
frecuentaron no pintan una imagen
tranquilizadora
entramos en 1984 el mismo año a la misma
escuela de la calle y de hecho podemos
citar una de las características que le
dieron a este momento su estima del
peligro entonces es peligroso para el
mismo es peligroso para el servicio y es
por eso que falló su carrera de espía le
devolvieron a leningrado de ahí viene
todo es decir hay que tomárselo muy en
serio porque desafortunadamente es capaz
de todo es crítica para youtube me lose
mou otra pregunta queda sin respuesta en
esta etapa podrían las sanciones
impuestas la comunidad internacional
hacerlo retroceder aunque solo sea un
poco nunca funcionó estos últimos años
sea en el caso de la guerra en georgia
la desidia o en los numerosos
envenenamientos de sus oponentes
los occidentales intentan esta vez
golpear un poco más fuerte y prueban
paralizar en parte el banco central ruso
con la congelación de sus reservas en el
extranjero
si rusia está excluida del sistema swift
y si el país no tiene más acceso a las
divisas extranjeras entonces putin no
tendrá más dinero para financiar sus
guerras ya vemos varios bancos rusos en
quiebra porque ya no tienen acceso al
capital de alphacan sugar made su
capital el impacto de esta medida y de
las otras sanciones tomadas podría tener
un efecto sobre la economía rusa los
occidentales esperan ver de esta forma
algunos pilares del poder ruso y una
parte de la población llamará putin a la
razón para evitar un colapso no obstante
nada nos dice que no seguirá con sus
planes